a teacher in Canada
is causing a little bit of a stir at his
school because he is showing up to class
dressed up as a woman with breasts that
are larger than than not not only larger
than the balloons at my child's birthday
party they're they're probably the size
of like four bowling balls each okay and
he has this there this was not
surgically done it would be impossible
to stretch the skin that far there's no
letter I can't tell you it's a double D
or e or F for G there's no letter it's
probably like a double X okay and so he
shows up with this prosthetic on dressed
up like a woman looking like a complete
crazy person which he is and the
students rightly raised some questions
and said hey you know this is kind of
weird right and there's videos of it
going around the internet and the guy
obviously I don't mean to make fun of
the guy the guy's obviously completely
out of his mind and should see a
psychiatrist and probably be committed
but he's now in our in our insane
Society is permitted not only to kind of
run around humiliating himself and
acting like a madman but he's he's
permitted to educate
miseducate students
and then this was brought to the school
and what did the school say
did the school take the side of reason
and normality and the students of the
parents or to the the school take the
side of sexual Anarchy and this Maniac
teacher you know the answer School said
we're aware of discussion on social
media and and in the media regarding
Oakville Trafalgar High School
this in a letter to parents we would
like to take this opportunity to
reiterate to our community that we are
committed to establishing and
maintaining a safe caring inclusive
Equitable and welcoming learning and
working environment for all students and
staff
we strive to promote positive learning
and ensure a safe environment for all
students and staff and Community
regardless of race age ability sex
gender identity gender expression sexual
orientation ethnicity
religion
now of course you can't do both you
can't protect the sort of sexual Maniacs
their freedom to do whatever they want
in public and the freedom of people
based on their religion not to have this
nonsense shove down their throats
what does this come down to
this isn't just okay we're going to pass
a law to stop this specific thing you
can only have Prosthetics that go up to
to seek up okay you can't go to double X
okay you can no obviously that's not how
you're going to handle it the problem
here
is that there are protections for what's
called soji sexual orientation and
gender identity
as long as there are legal Protections
in Canada or the United States now we
have them in both places as long as
there are legal protections where you
can't discriminate on the basis of
sexual orientation and gender identity
then you can't stop this because someone
could just say my sexual orientation is
to have like gigantic triple Z
prosthetic breasts on even though I'm a
man and to wear high heels and stilettos
in class and a wig that's my gender
identity that's my sexual orientation
and expression and if you dare oppose me
you you awful parents and students and
people with two brain cells and and a
normal sense of things if you ever
propose me I'm going to take you to
court
and and as long as you have a protection
for this bizarre amorphous category
sexual orientation gender identity
that's what you're going to get the only
way out of this is to repeal those
protections
it they're ridiculous those protections
weren't in place until just a few years
ago because Neil Gorsuch decided to
completely squish on the Supreme Court
and enshrined in civil rights law
protection for soji for for gender
expression or whatever
well what can be done by a rogue lawyer
on the Supreme Court can be undone
especially when it's this radical but
conservatives have to go that far if if
conservatives think that they're going
to solve this problem by just squishing
in the middle and saying okay well you
know your mini skirt has to listen
Mister your mini skirt has to go down at
least to three inches above your knee
then we're not going to win well Mr okay
you can only we've got to approve your
prosthetic by the Bureau of transgender
bras or something it's not going to work
okay you've got to rip this out root and
Branch right now go to epicwell.com use
promo code Knowles the daily wire has
been closely following the tragic death
of an actress earlier this month and
however tragic and shocking the
underreported story is that she died
without a will leaving her son to file
court papers to control her estate do
not let this happen to you it's a
nightmare a scenario do you really want
to burden your kids with this while
they're still grieving take five minutes
today set up your will with epic will a
complete will package which epic well
provides you with so much more than just
the protection of your assets they look
at your whole Legacy your finances your
medical wishes your responsibilities as
a parent or caregiver they bundle your
last will living will Health Care power
of attorney HIPAA release and durable
Financial power of attorney in one easy
package to make sure that your entire
Legacy everything you leave behind is
protected and
they make it incredibly easy and
affordable it only costs 119 bucks for a
single person to create a will and when
you use promo code Knowles you will save
10 percent do yourself and your loved
ones a favor make sure you have a will
in place today go to epicwill.com use
promo code Knowles to save 10 on Epic
Wheels complete wheel package that's
epicwill.com promo code Knowles I'm so
glad you like that clip now here's what
I need you to do you've got to ring that
Bell subscribe get the notifications on
this YouTube channel we'll see you next
time
[Music]
thank you